what's with the jeans there's no mommy
like my mommy welcome to your mom's
house we are here in your mom's house
again with of course christina pazsitzky
hello I'm Tom Segura the always
delightful red band and a very special
mommy guest mr. Ryan Sickler right now
are you saying no not only am I excited
just made me heart with that opening man
specially designed for you I really felt
like it was as soon as I heard it yeah
and if those people listening out there
don't know what it is that was high
school football coaches yes
firing their team up for a big game that
was a documentary right the documentary
people year of the bull directed by Todd
movement I believe is his name and it
follows the Miami northwestern Bulls in
Liberty City section of Miami a real
powerhouse football team and Ryan and I
really got into this documentary I mean
obsessively I would say is a safe word
to use to the point where there's a lot
like a lot of people you know they have
things started playing in high school
people have movie quotes and a lot of
times they're from you know just iconic
movies whatever it may be things that
you saw in middle school high school
right and they they always reference
like the line from the movie
this documentary had the same effect on
us where to this day there's lines from
that that are totally part of our
lexicon like we just say shit completely
the same over and over yep you're like a
son to me man did like a parent did like
a parent
wait Ryan did you find this originally
so yeah I was Pisa
and we say Pisa to each other yeah it's
not pizza and my friend Christie oddly
enough for a girl has taken to it like
we have oh she was I remember uh it's so
weird cuz we it first aired on Showtime
and we would I don't remember if we even
had like were able to record it did you
record it child it's amazing yeah I mean
it's crazy right oh that's fucked up
I've never seen this before
it's hilarious you're the bull a high
school football refilm it's on YouTube
yeah well actually the on YouTube they
only have the highlights oh really
yeah it's just it's just clip moments it
says the document I guess it says part
one and stuff but it's not it's just
clips we still have to get the film I
don't I feel like you don't understand
the impact that this documentary has had
in in my life oh yeah husbands because
not only do we cherish this documentary
but my husband has taken to yelling the
phrases
I mean I would say for the last three is
it three years now more more more yrs
okay so I mean it's little even just
we'll be in bed laying together and a
quiet moment and then addressing the
team here this shit should be we were
excited we were excited we were what we
would not let one player fuck this up
no ruin this fuckin opportunity we got
it is shit all come around
fucking years where you go simple a team
that could make it up there shit is
amazing that's how you motivate kids
that is one of the comments underneath
the clip so I was watching it what is a
guy he's like I played on this team and
those guys got us ready for life and in
the movie the principal the bet one of
the best lines actually is the principal
of this school goes look man I can't
tell you what the state what the square
root of a hypotenuse is I tell you a lot
about nobody can and you're like that's
a perfect man like he's not I'm not
worried about the ins and outs with all
these numbers and shit and they weren't
building a team what were they building
there they weren't building the team the
franchise it was a program program
that's right they were putting a program
is there any way you could queue up my
favorite thing of all is the second clip
I say like the the second one in the
email it starts at like one minute
exactly or something yeah yeah this is
the pregame one that we've probably
referenced the most this one is the
first time
ice looks like 7:30 right there there's
no way you could hear that shit and not
either be terrified or ready to fucking
kill somebody that guy I wish he would
have been my high school coach man or
should have been my dad you know what's
funny is when you play this for me like
I didn't even understand what he was
talking understand it I mean your house
I grab your remote control yeah and I
changed a channel and I'm wearing the
same shirt you got on it doesn't even
make you know what's really going on
there though right now I'm using DNA
okay first he starts off by telling them
by describing it to the old cliche in
sports is like this is our house then
he's saying that like your mother
literally is understand so like we're
not gonna lose with your mother watching
from the stands right and then he says
what's going on is that these guys are
coming over to your house they're
grabbing the remote control and they're
controlling they're trying to watch TV
on your fucking TV motherfucking TV it's
like that's a TV that you watch these
guys are coming over and they're trying
to Kotori TV and then he goes on to say
what they did was they came over now in
our house they're putting on the same
shit you got on and then after that
they're going fuck you so what are you
gonna do about
that train of logic is amazing for high
school sports that's that's the best
pregame speech I've ever heard in my
life
yeah ever well what do they normally
tell you I never played sports what do
you hear I'll tell you if any school
outside that specific city in that
specific high school if there were any
coaches to talk to any kids like that
they'd be fired you never work again but
in that area it was cool it works well
you don't know if it was cool yeah yeah
I mean I feel like good here's here was
a typical like pregame talk for high
school sports is like all right guys
you've were put in a lot of work you
know we've gone through this in practice
you've been training a lot go out there
and get them yeah that's like a typical
on three yeah one two three win and
these guys are like you're not gonna
embarrass us they don't give a fuck
about those kids they're not going out
like that yeah yeah that's like this
coach do you have the clip of what
happens so T Diddy who's the focal if
there's a paralyzed oh right yeah
temporarily paralyzed after a game
couldn't feel you know they took him out
on a stretcher neck brace and everything
and he the one positive mentor he has in
this whole thing's an ex player from the
Steelers I don't remember his name and
he's tone I'm like you know you're 17
don't go play next week like you have a
life ahead of you and these guys are you
know basically you need to put me in a
pussy and get back out on the field and
he did say again Not Me Not Me Not Me
a--
and that's the cold yeah hitting the
player in tackling life who was
paralyzed weeks ago yeah and he has to
be separated then work your shit out
right here let them work this shit out
red band press pause real quick so as
somebody who's never seen that before
what do you think this is intense
this shit right here that I'm watching
right now was the first time I'm like
alright that's fucked it's fucked up
right now do you guys know the history
of this movie like was this coach like
like fucking this know this high school
is like in a really bad section of Miami
okay and they're known for just fucking
massacring other high schools in
football like they just they produce NFL
players over and over and over and like
big-time college players all the time
every year and it's just it's a rough
neighborhood and they have just you know
rough coaches to go with it but it's
this the whole movie you should watch
the movie the movies really good this is
like a Netflix thing yeah you can
totally know yeah yeah and I recommend
anybody listening if you want like if
you've never seen it it is a pretty
awesome documentary you agree oh yeah oh
yeah it's it's it's addicting like you
know the coaches the players the
principal everyone's a character and
it's it's I know from these clips it
doesn't look funny but it is
laugh-out-loud funny there's a lot of
really rich I know that last part was
fun I was so into this and laughs I
would laugh so much
he was really but I would laugh so much
especially like with Ryan like as we
would say it to each other and you would
like sometimes you wouldn't expect it
coming and or how it could be it and
then I wrote the director an email that
I was like because I found his email
address somewhere and I was like this is
the funniest movie I've ever seen
because I was getting so much joy out of
it right I didn't meet and then I I sent
it and he never wrote back and I was
like oh like this sounds like I'm really
not trying to mock it like I wasn't
saying like haha I know that you're
trying to make the movie is legitimately
really good documentary it is
there's just moments these guys more
wild characters man like they're they're
saying like yes I'm going out like that
like that's just just one that's that's
two kids took it it's objectively funny
like me yeah that pregame speech as
intense as it is like the more you watch
it the more you just laugh your ass off
about because especially since he
stumbles he's in the fucking remote
control like he's trying to find the
word that shit makes me laugh so hard
I cannot what why do you think that that
style humor is what what you like what
triggers yeah well I think we've had
this discussion so many times about
everybody has you could argue at least
one definitive trigger that always makes
you laugh for me inappropriateness
outbursts I find like violent outbursts
not ones that like not somebody getting
like kicked in the head but like yelling
screaming violently where do you feel
like it's not appropriate to the
situation I don't know why I figured I
it must be that like when I was younger
I saw something like that in my reaction
the way that I handled it was laughing
has always made me laugh anything
inappropriate for like the the
environment the circumstance if the
behavior is like out of line for what's
going on for me automatic I can't
fucking control myself like I start just
just yelling do you have like a trigger
like that yeah like some of the Tony
Hinchcliffe I don't know if you know him
or not
he was tweeting the other day that how
he was a seagull pooped in his mouth
right there makes me giggle so much like
I think that the idea of him getting
pooped in the mouth that's funny that's
very funny
Christina's trigger hands down is poop
oh yeah related makes me laugh so
fucking hard we could be watching
anything in if there's poopy yeah oh my
god that and I like inappropriateness
mm-hmm and I really like like I know
this is really bad but like mental
illness illness
yeah and it's it's because my mom worked
for a psychiatrist when I was a little
girl and I would sit in the office
sometimes and watch these patients come
in and be like Oh dirt today okay really
how many like how much three G spoonfuls
and like I don't know it just really
gets me maybe because I fear it so much
to like I'm like oh maybe I'm crazy and
there's something in that that and but
by the way really like you know anything
sex jokes
yeah references to like like violence
and sex for you is like the tops tops
and like soft some movie I just change
the channel and the guy was like well
why don't you fucking twist her clit off
and I just like I just got I just
started laughing my ass off I had no
idea the context of what it was being
said but because I think it was
inappropriate and oh and like sexually
kind of over the top for me hilarious
there were sexual scenario we would come
up with as a joke like we're like what's
the worst fantasy and like okay oh yeah
I'm I'm the janitor I'm the general
yeah no I'm the janitor you're the
principal the principal I'm the janitor
of a of like a major corporation and I
think I clean the office and I'm in
there I come in my mopping the floor and
then what I do is I you're like hey what
are you looking at I'm like nothing and
then you tell me to do what I want so I
I staple your tits to the desk dock your
head in the dirty mouths water
yeah yeah that's what's found its way
into my act now you know it's true it
can see I have a perfect story then if
you like handicapped stuff and if you
like Pope no I feel better than any
camera right this is a true story that
you might find humorous I don't like
that this happened this way but this
happened okay my friend I live next to a
handicapped person
and the kid was like handicapped and it
was kind of like he was very nice and
friendly but one of those like won't
leave you alone handicapped kids you
know that's like coming to your door all
the time like hey I made flowers and
you're like oh yeah that's nice think so
you know but he did it like you know
maybe 20 times a day you know put this
to my friend and so my friends like I am
so sick and tired of this shit and so he
pooped in a cup and then said it was
chocolate and gave it to the kid so my
friend called me I was like Brian come
over here get on your bike I got
something to show you
and so I'm like all right what's going
on and they I come over the kids just
sitting in the garage going can I ride
your lawnmower in the end I'm like whoa
why is it what's always a mouth
if you drink this lemonade yeah sorry
yeah we're in fifth grade all right
answer again he drank the piss and then
and then like a week later my friend
Hartig I was 25 right yeah the weekly or
my friend got addicted to doing it so
you just want to rampages I don't know
and then finally the parents found out
and he got in trouble yeah then sit down
with like the two families you can
imagine your son like now she he fed my
my son my retarded son shit and the
retarded yeah and the kid just wanted to
ride a lawnmower you know oh my friend
felt so bad I feel bad for hearing that
your friend felt bad for for making him
eat his shit I mean but no no no you
gotta think about it now he feels really
yeah he's my good friends wait I want to
ask Ryan what his is before I tell you
what really makes me laugh
have you guys ever seen that GG Allin
documentary called it's hated GG on the
murder - oh yeah oh my god it's my
favorite one well it's high it's the
pappases all that stuff yes so wildly
inappropriate it's so much food more
food than you'd ever want in a mental
illness
it's an appropriateness and there's the
best thing ever when GG Allin is
performing at a university in a
cafeteria and he on he peels banana gets
naked and then shows the banana up his
ass yeah it makes me laugh so hard and
he has a comically small penis yes
that's always out I mean it's like it's
really tiny really tiny and it's always
out he's just
what's up Alan wait no Ryan what's your
thing I have to knowing do you have a
trigger yeah I'm pretty much the same as
you are I like public inappropriate I
really do love it an aggression I really
like aggression I'd much rather see
someone beat someone then out duel them
with words yeah buddy yeah yeah it's
fire me for someone loser shame like
fuck this and just go physically attack
some more than to just stand there and
yeah you know I'll duel them with this
irregularity this that this highlights
to me that like this movie got us
yelling so much that in in that type of
public inappropriate aggression did I
started doing it oh yeah in public -
yeah and one time we were I love this
story were rolling down Fairfax and
there was like halfway down the block
there's this this black guy who's like I
think he's carrying like a bag he's
walking down the street and from inside
the car I just scream it but the windows
are up and like like it was like a cute
and another time
yeah another time I was on I was doing
radio and on the radio show they had
patched in these two guys and they had
two guests essentially two callers were
calling in talking to each other and
they were disagreeing and it happened to
be it was two black guys and they were
like hold on a second man and going back
and forth and so for fun I just leaned
up to the mic and ask at the height of
their yelling I was just like fuck and
they both went silent serious yeah and I
feel like this movie coached me for that
well it drained you this movie got you
trained a hundred percent ready for the
year of the ball yeah yeah I think we
should do prank calls with your gift
Tommy Lee we call we should we're in the
south and do or like do this voice Ryan
you wish you'd do this - yeah
just want to do prank oh we should we
should call somebody with that voice
okay I'll try to set that up no weights
just to put that to put that first week
all I want to tell you something read
ban that first clip that you showed the
very beginning yeah just to put that
into context what's going on there is
that that's halftime of the state
championship game and to just to give
you an idea of what most halftime are
like they are like that they are a lot
like that usually people are taking
shits taking pisses but coaches are
usually like here's what's working
here's what's not working and they
usually pull up a chalkboard and they'll
go when they run this play we need to
defend it with that right that's kind of
the general manager these guys just said
was like why is the defense not working
that's what's repeated and then they
smack the shit out of them why it's not
working why the fuck isn't that working
Wow that's how you coach this that's so
awesome now it'll be known it should be
known that this school not only is in a
rough neighborhood but the fans
themselves actually I think I read
online a story cuz I've had a couple of
people from this high school follow me
on Facebook and things like that yeah I
see that we put these quotes out there
about it and they're like oh my god and
they have a fan bus they have fan buses
that go to every game every high school
game and on one of the fan buses of
adults full of adults they pulled off
like six hang that was a movie oh was it
that was very Beach
I was very what happened was when I was
in high school I was in high school in
Vero Beach I went to st. edward's a
small school and up the street was Vero
Beach High School a big school and one
year in the playoffs vero was playing
Miami northwestern which is like a big
deal so I went to the games and Vero
Beach Miami northwestern this was in
like 1990 five or six 102 to 95 or 96
and as we're leaving the game you hear
pop pop pop pop pop like that
so popcorn was going off well we run out
let's go home
the next day in the paper they said they
went on to the fan bus and they found
eight oh I'm sorry yeah I mean not mean
to do a disservice yeah they found they
came right didn't come and then that was
so intense that the following week Veera
went down to Miami to pay Miami South
Ridge which is another huge high school
down there and they each player got a
police escort from the bus each player
Claire high school high school got a
escort from the bus to the locker room
it's also amazing cuz the fans will
actually bet money on these kids
yeah they show this that's on a show and
it's funny cuz they're like look how
much money I got in one kid's like I
don't think we're supposed to be saying
this on camera but the adults will give
them you'll see them run over the stands
put some money in their hand and then
off but these guys know did you play me
I played soccer and it was same as I was
football and I wasn't allowed to do both
spores
zonkers hard as shit to it's hard work
man running kick a ball I didn't do shit
in high school I just smoked cigarettes
and yeah was golf and stuff you were
golf yeah how God we call super God
you're a sure rangers the other thing
dance their game you know gay anthem we
should point out that like I think all
of us have tried to get people to watch
the documentaries we like that's the
thing that we do we're into getting
people to watch our you're the
documentaries a lot right yeah but I
tend to watch just like by mistake
documentaries you know like there's no
kind of direction like I just watched
one about like corn the other day um you
know then it's like very random
documentaries i watch ya know corn make
the buy yummy stuff oh yeah
it's about the foodie food no it's
called corn Oh
yeah yeah there's really I just saw you
guys we were talking about the other day
I saw inside job
you know that's what you see it yeah
it's really good yeah really good it's
basically about the financial meltdown
of like Oh 8:00 and like how how it's an
inside job basically everybody who is
like in charge of the financial industry
is you know Riggs it scumbag piece of
human garbage basically you know they
they're in it for themselves
yeah just kind of shows you how it's all
connected politically and corporately
they all kind of are tied in together
that's why I like the regulations will
really have never have any effect or
will never actually be in effect because
people that are in a position of power
corporately end up being in a position
of power position of power politically
and they won't allow laws to ruin what
they've got going on with clients in
finance you know so animals you know
yeah it's pretty yeah and it's pretty
hope that makes you feel good mmm I feel
good here in America wait let's get a
little background on right yeah I know
this but our listeners don't know this
what about tell us like where you're
from I'm some I am I was um I'm
originally from Baltimore I was born in
West Baltimore city that reads City
Tabriz yep and lived there for a little
while then we moved out to the county
because my dad wanted you know better
things for us than the city could
provide like a yard because fools chance
at living past the age of nine yeah it
like that and then I grew up out in the
county I had my family in the city so we
spent a lot of our days nights and
summers in the city and the county and
what is Baltimore known for murder
okay crabs crabs crabs it's the murder
capital and all that I understand drugs
up there it's always up in like the top
ten yeah
yeah yeah let's say they always place
they always play they metal every year
there's a metal well I'm not judging I
was born in Windsor Ontario which is
across from Detroit so it's not very
glamorous either so sorry ago you were
saying no I can judge what I didn't hear
you wouldn't say anything didn't say oh
my god that's scary did you hear that
what today is 4/20 did you guys
celebrate yes we did we were gonna shave
this down to a little Jordyn birthday it
is oh yeah I love that Jordan started
rocking this - you realize that we were
talking about how you know how Jordan
had a Hitler stache for like a few
months
Wow you rocked it for that long and he
he bro yeah he did and he filmed a hain
one of his Hanes commercials at least
one of them in them
all right saying you know he showed up
and they're like hey and then they're
like that's Michael Jordan like you
don't you don't say shit to him about
they probably do you want us to like
reshape that he was like nah like don't
touch my shit and they're like alright
cool hey Jordan's gonna shoot with his
hailer mustache like good to go right
and like yeah yeah everything's fine
well you can't you can't step up and
tell Michael Jordan well didn't he beat
AIDS I think you mean the Knicks no the
Magic Johnson um be a magical Johnson
hey did you really do use Michael Jordan
it's all the same like I watched sports
I'm not a lesbian that's horrible man no
Michael Jordan has a Hitler mustache
Johnson beat aids that's basically
that's all you need to know about the
NBA right now that's all I can be if
anyone's like what do you know about the
NBA these days that's all you I know
Kobe Bryant called Selena
fagelah he did not even mean people call
him worse things like that i-i-i was
saying this the other day that the thing
that kills me about that about the whole
you know kobe being you know saying
faggot or whatever he said is the
issuing of that apology like first the
criticism how they're gonna be like it's
so horrible I'm not arguing that it's
like it's a bad word and you're saying
something it's a you know it's a slur
for a whole group of people but this
idea that he's am really sorry that that
was in the heat of the moment let's not
act like you don't say that fucking a
hundred times a day right now you say it
into your teammates you probably say it
to the coach you probably pull your car
in a Staples Center take the keys toss
them over your head and say Park my shit
faggot to whoever does oh yes watch it
dude and I'm sure he goes I'm sure you
know he goes home and says it to whoever
else is that the Hat like it's not got a
dick he's sucking it when we were kids
we played a game called smear the queer
right okay I had no idea what queer was
yeah I didn't even know I didn't know
that it meant a guy that wanted to put
his dick in another guy's ass yeah I
didn't know that that's what it meant
when I was throwing the fucking football
up and catching it or I never would have
been the queer yeah oh and I mean like
that's just a name yeah yeah smear the
queer yeah you're the idiot that has the
football yeah that's it you know it's
everyone understand you know I think
everyone over for goes through their
thing of having to establish that they
they can't be you know smeared in public
but then again everybody calls each
other console because C's and I don't
fucking the point the guy out Kobe was
saying this to somebody saying it to the
ref that he was trying to hurt he's
trying to say hopefully right so you
know I think everybody understands that
emotion like when you like somebody just
like did something new or hurt you in
some way he's not saying you you know
you are stop you're such a guy who fucks
other guys
I scream like he's just trying to say
something to get anger out of him but
the apology I'm bothered by the apology
more than him saying I hate those
insincere apology I'll buy them at all
would be like well now now everything's
cool because we released oh wait a
minute don't these players call each
other and bombs
so then how come nobody's offended if
Kobe calls Michael Jordan or magical
Johnson because that it's actually a
really legitimate question thank you now
people people I think would answer at
different ways one of the reasons is
because most people agree that like if
you're black then you can say what you
know you can say the word that is the
disparate like the between term for
black like you know whatever you are you
are laughs like that derogatory term for
sure so like if it was like an ice
skating tournament they're like what's
up faggot
I would go to everyone what I can't hear
and I'm Pro gay whatever you suck dicks
before at all oh yeah god yeah make sure
you put an s on the end of that I can't
sit and listen to gay guys tell me that
the same fag is the same as the n-word
is so he's waited like there weren't a
bunch of fags grouped together and
brought here and made to build this
country without right like you know
other than marrying you can't you have
nothing but rights you you've been what
do you what's the word I'm looking for
you've been discriminated discriminated
against thank you but you've always had
rights yeah you've always been able to
vote you've always been able to use the
same bathrooms you've always been able
to use a water fountain yeah no Jim Crow
laws for I think it's a legit they're
legitimate like griped they've been
hated upon and don't forget it's when
you're young and you're gay and you're a
little boy and we'll call you faggot and
oh that's terrible
but that's why that's the argument for
for why
it's not cool to say that like horns if
you use fag or faggot to a gay person
that is as hateful as you can be to them
like that's a horrible thing to do
but it just has like the reality of it
is that people say that all the time
without a homosexual context to it you
know I'm saying like where it's just
like well like it has nothing to do with
like straight guys say it to each other
about like you know what you know are
you gonna we're gonna fix your car right
yeah no that's the exact their problem
is that it's so embedded the the the the
homosexual hatred is so embedded in the
culture that you guys don't even make
the association that it's homophobic
that's right they're saying right like
you shouldn't even because it's not even
a thought of like hey faggot this bag at
that it's even more pejorative right I
mean like Plus has a majority black
people are a lot more scarier than
faggots oh no that's a good point right
if that was a documentary about math
class will you what do you what do you
open what it was Oh yours it was on 16
check out that new flashlight I got the
new blue one oh it's fresh if you want
to put your finger in it have you used
it no it's really never been used this
one yeah it's nice but that's a fresh
one see if you ever want to know what a
fresh one is I keep hearing like she
wanted to get in how do you clean it how
do you keep don't I don't that's a good
joke mom I actually just actually just
shoot into it I don't want to use it now
it's just to see how much I can come do
you really come in that today
for real no don't you have extra ones
yeah those are my two old ones an angry
tired both of them why they've been just
rolling around on the carpet to mine we
have a girlfriend yeah how was your
girlfriend
is that a picture great that's what's up
you know it sucks what is when you're in
a new relationship and you have like a
lot of sex and then you have to keep on
doing that like all the time because you
can't just start you know acting like
hey we don't have to do it five times a
day oh oh that's your problem that's
your issue right now okay so that's your
rich people problems kind of thing going
on yeah wish I was rich you know what
sucks man is when you have like these
multiple accounts I mean you get so much
interest on a million dollars that you
don't know how to place that shit you
know I'm saying rich and pussy
sickle-cell
sorry that's another people don't know
that's a nickname for dead and sick
let's let's let's also let people know
that you created that nickname that's
not like you met me and people were
already like oh no that's something you
guys created for me it's caught on how
it happened at your workplace one time
my friend Reena well this is after we
started using this a lot from years yeah
six years and since we've known Ryan
Sickler he has been sickle-cell which
you have officially coined black cancer
somebody that's like hey black cancer
like that was a big thing like a
nickname cuz those we don't know it is
it is a disease that is only in the
african-american community correct it is
a genetic I feel like there are some
people outside the african-american
female I just know I know but I'm saying
isn't it female within African I don't
know all right I've never done the
studies on the nickname you guys have
created however I was working one day
and Christina's friend coincidentally I
didn't know worked in the same building
and
on the other side of my desk was this
this black kid and she came over and she
yelled from probably 20 yards away
hey sickle cell and I hear this little
black kid he was an effeminate black kid
seeing a side of you explain this black
kid like yeah that's what they call me
shit kills a lot of people you probably
know that's a big call me What did he
say was he like what the fuck he was
kind of like you know like what do you
say that oh that that's the explanation
like there's no good reason they call
you became eeeh when did um I wanted to
answer this on the show when did you
first do stand up again cuz you did it
once or something and then say yeah I
started when I was 20 in in Baltimore
and I did it for a few months she did it
a few times yeah then it's like every
week they're at this one little club
called Winchester's on Water Street I
think it might still be there and and
then you know life happened not to put
myself through school and get do it
again until I was 27
wow that's a long time a long time now
when did we meet you how old that was
Tommy was 23
probably 91 let's see no I need nine
eight nine no I moved here cuz I
graduated college 99 and I didn't start
doing stand-up until maybe Oh - really
that's what I would have made you go -
yeah yeah no - no - Dan yeah yeah the
first time I heard Ryan I was a he was
at the good bar with a good bar yeah
good bar was on Sunset right the border
of Beverly Hills Beverly High and
there's a curtain separating like the
stage yep I was like you were on stage
and I was like huh the funny black guy
so I'm stoked right now I was like I
want to meet this guy and then you came
off where's the guy that was on there
like that's him right there
I was like nah I was a black guy who was
on stage like no it's
right here and to this day sometimes
people think you're black when they I
get it a lot really mm-hmm
when people talk to me on the phone for
the first time they're like oh it's
expecting a black guy I get it I get it
I've been told I have an old black man
sold more time I believe oh that's for
sure yeah you call me a grouchy dog
you're like a grouchy junkyard dog yeah
I'm like one of these guys like Fred
Sanford yeah you should live in a
junkyard with your son Lamont do you
have a harmonica ah do you really do it
yeah would you hike today yes it's so
upsetting how much this guy hides there
so I mean let's let's be let's not call
it hiking I mean I walk fire trail but
you walk like you did Runyon Canyon no I
know it's fine private man weekend every
day every day
I've decided you can't be fat and lazy
you can be fat or you can be lazy but
you can't be fucking fat you're neither
now though I'm still a little lazy you
are in high cos that's good
how many miles do you like anywhere from
four to six fuck out here that's amazing
I saw a bobcat out there the other day
first time I've been going there for
years and we know you're not supposed to
have dogs all homes but some people do
it those were good movies I came up the
hill or Thomas that come up that hill
come up there ham I saw what I thought
was a dog off leash and it stopped and
it looked at me and I was like I had
panic like sheer panic those are my
violin I'm there's no cage between me
and this animal it was like the size of
a dog but it looked like a cat and my
first thought was like I'm gonna fuck
this thing off with my water bottle but
you said I was gonna fuck this thing so
far
I think really well on my feet in panic
situations and there have been a lot of
emergency situations and I think real
well and my initial second thought was
if that may not be logical but my
initial second thought was and then I'm
gonna take my headphone cords and wrap
it around its neck okay that's my game
plan a case at a tactic but in
gracefully and just run down the hill
and I was like that's probably better
for both of us
what's this whole go back to I've been
in a lot of emergency situations I know
I really yeah I've had to have you have
have you ever had to call 9-1-1 for
something real yeah a couple times
that's the situation I would say yeah
yeah how many times you done that I just
did it on my birthday I walked into a
7-eleven what I walk into a 7-eleven
here in the valley and there's a guy
sitting on the floor gushing blood in
the head geez there's three or four
people in line and the clerk is standing
there he goes hey watch out for that guy
was going to the ATM I was like oh this
guy who's bleeding massively from the
head right now and his bike is parked in
the store some think maybe this dude
fell off his head I'm like what smile at
this guy he won't look up he is sitting
indian-style his head down you can see
flesh pulled aside up flap open gushing
blood people walking over him right I
step around to get money anyway just me
and but I was concerned I was like
what's up with this dude in the guy's
like I don't know I'm like what do you
mean you don't know that's all your
floor blood eating like out straight up
how you want to call 9-1-1 I'm like you
call my mom one he's fuckin dialed 9-1-1
he's an indian dude hands me the phone
I'm like Hello and they're like 901 put
me on hold
yeah yeah always then they come back
with attitude what's the emergency on my
I'm in a 7-eleven there's a guy bleeding
from the head hole please and then they
transfer me to the bleeding head
department I guess and then and I'm the
whole time I'm like if I was shot on the
floor right now dying the whole time
that's what I was thinking like I'd be
fucking freaking out yeah yeah so then
they're like what's the emergency I'm
like there's a guy in 7-eleven bleeding
massively from the head and like what
happened to a monkey I don't know the
clerk said he doesn't know but he won't
help me out I say what's the address the
car feels like 131 I'm like 131 he's
like no eight five four Tillman
five for teens like no.13 one I'm like
dude what is it what is the address here
back and forth back and forth and I said
finally I was like printer receipt
pretty fucking receipt from your
register he prints it out I look at the
receipt it's like one three seven one
six Vineland I was like you're an
asshole max get there in like five
minutes - what's up I'm like I don't
know this guy in there bleeding from the
head take it from there
just mark you kept her cool that's the
whole point well that one wasn't really
an emergency situation but I just that
popped in my head cause it's the most I
had a similar wall nine-one-one I had
that one I told you about where my
sister was like what was that back there
this is a frame yeah and I'm driving out
on the in in Florida on highway 60 and I
was like I don't know she was like there
was something back there in that field
and I was like I don't fucking go back
there it's run a one-way street and she
was like there was something in that
field and I was like gee and like I
almost would have been like well too bad
you know
so I just I decide to go turn around
have to do a huge like this one-way
street turn left back another one-way
street and then we go we've seen the
field again I don't see anything at
first and then I noticed that there is a
light in the middle of the field
I was like ah shit there is something
there so we pull up again we park and as
we get out I see that this field is
surrounded by a fence but the fence at
one point has like a huge chunk of it
missing like just gone and you can tell
it's like it's ripped from where it was
so then we oh my gosh shit this is
something as I walk a little closer I
see that that light is from a motorcycle
and the motorcycle is kind of like just
laying there the lights kind of beaming
up and so you're like shit there's a
motorcycle there and then you look
around in about 25 yards from the
motorcycle you see a body so I walk up
to the body and I was like holy shit you
really start to panic you know and it
was weird I didn't want to touch the guy
I'm like hey and I started I start being
polite and like sir
sorry excuse me sir sir and then I just
reach my hand out slowly and finally
touch him on the shoulder I'm like touch
it sir sir and then I just hear like and
the guy sits up and as he sits up he
ejaculates
into your mouth like a bird that's there
was no emergency after all he know when
he sits up his head flaps open skull is
open you know and you jerked off I came
into his head
but I used it as a sealant yeah yes I
put his head back together and to this
day he still sends me thank you cards
sealed with common besides if you hadn't
come in my head so I sent him cum
baskets under Christmas no I they the
best part was that we call nine-one-one
my sister's freaking out we get them to
come out they land a helicopter in the
field and then the the guy the cops
talking me about what happened I go
explained to him he goes well you know
I'd hate for you to be a good Samaritan
then go to jail yourself I was like what
usually I could smell that alcohol in
your dog that was like I had like half a
beer he's like you might want to get out
of here I was like all right man yeah
later just get in the car wait what you
weren't were you were driving yeah but I
was driving but it was just like I've
literally had like half a beer and I was
like I'm fine and the cop was like go
ahead and get back in that car and drive
out I had one that happened to me kind
of the kind of kind of same wine I was
going to work and I got really baked
before I went to work I worked as a
manager of a independent movie theater
they only played like like small artsy
movies in Columbus yeah in Columbus
that's the manager there and so I was
like going to work and I'm all dressed
up with my tie and stuff and my favorite
CD garden band had a new CD that day and
oh my call is the first time listening
pretty much just pump it up to the
stereo driving to work slowly I'm like
on the highway going about 65 something
like that 75 and I see this guy dart off
the right side of the street he was
holding a big long pipe like a PCP pipe
it's like what the fuck is this guy
doing on the highway like oh that's like
some kind of worker or something then I
look straight in the car in front of me
hits this guy standing in the middle of
a street with another pipe full on I see
his face go through the windshield
snap over the car smack over my car and
I slammed on the brakes mmm his shoe
flies off lands in my passenger side
window right on my thing right when I
stop I look over my god fucking shoe you
know creepy I get out of the car and the
guys are sitting there fucking so much
blood and brain coming out of her head
it was fucking like it's like his whole
head was emptied you know and he was
like shaking doing a stupid crazy shake
shit and like all these construction
workers started coming down I guess what
happened they were working on a bridge
and a couple pipes fell down and he was
trying to pick up the pipes off the
highway before anyone ran over it and
the one guy points to me because Road
not wearing shirts and it was really
sweating they were all very strong and
muscular and this one guy had like his
hair come to a they were all not wearing
shirts and they point to me they're like
give me your fucking shirt man I need to
wrap his head up and I look down at my
like this is like a nice dress shirt for
work and I'm like I'm like his brains
out so his head yeah and I'm like then I
have like what am i a being a dick here
I go okay so I say take my shirt off and
suddenly this guy just throws his shirt
down I'm like oh okay this happened in
like a microsecond you know this is like
about this brain am I gonna save a life
for sure something horrifying the part
try to block out of your head Hollywood
Boulevard when you saw that kid on the
tricycle oh this is this is bad okay I
forgot about it you're right I was on
Hollywood Boulevard and it was Sun was
setting and there was a family a mom and
two kids jaywalking and on the opposite
way I see them very they're cutting
through traffic it was major traffic and
this little kid on his tricycle just got
popped off just someone just hit him and
the kid I saw bounce on the sidewalk on
the asphalt and I was just it was so
fucking awful it was intense awful
I came so hard you said oh yeah do you
think of
I rub them out
i've called 9-1-1 four people just on
the floor a lot on the sidewalk like
people just walk over it
yeah and they will they'll put you on
hold look like now wine can you hold
them like no no all from a cellphone out
here it goes to the chp it doesn't
actually go yeah they transfer you yeah
then you get trans man cuz if someone
breaks in your house and you're
terrified like really no no one hold
hold on a second you know what someone
disagrees and he told me not to keep
bringing this down but a friend of mine
her girlfriend went out with a bunch of
her girlfriends one night drinking and
they got fucked up and she decided I'm
gonna be responsible and I'm gonna take
a cab home so she takes a cab home and
the cab driver knew she was drunk and
she got to her front door and when she
was fumbling with the key she got
attacked from I know what happened was
the cabbie pulled around the corner and
followed her because he knew she was
fucked up and was gonna rape her so he
gets her in the you know the door and
puts on the ground he's gonna ready to
rape her and she's screaming dude
doesn't know she's engaged fiancees home
ok comes down and fucks him up the guy
police and the police tell her that this
happens to women all you have no idea
how many drunk women do the responsible
thing by themselves go home and these
will attack them robbed them rape them
whatever I just learned that no my
friend Sarah burns and I we do this
thing where we used to live close enough
where we we get drunk and then put the
other one in a cab and she would go home
is that I would meet the cabbie
and be like what's your name sir you
know whatever and then I get his fucking
number and be like sir if my friend
isn't making home in five minutes if she
doesn't call me I'm gonna call the
police you would say that to him
absolutely servers I mean that trade we
don't how we do that well because you
guys will never get ready yeah I was I
would say I would be like get the fuck
out of my cab if you think about that
person fuck you lady I would I've never
seen a female cab driver ever neat never
I know they're rare they're like
lifeguard I don't know what I don't know
like swimming anymore afraid of the
water yeah
what cavies female cabbies I feel like -
well it's so date or working at 7-eleven
you don't see many women working at
7-eleven either red band you play the
the very first clip again now that we
know the context of it for our listeners
yes this is half time you're down by 10
points okay let's get this let's get
this defense working Christmas Carol
they have the entire team crammed into
one tiny shower stall and they wear
these like welders gloves and they beat
them on the side of their helmets thank
God completely they should do like some
kind of written song tonight you know
there should be some kind of like
fucking remit should auto-tune that yeah
auto-tune it did you guys hear the story
about David Byrne um what's name crisped
Charlie best yeah the closeted gay
senator and Florida well the former
governor who ran for Sanger he didn't
win okay so he used David Burns Talking
Heads song road to nowhere illegally
without David Burns consent which you
you know that they know is not okay - of
course yeah and Dina Byrnes really like
I don't endorse like this closeted
asshole piece of shit human scum face
and ensued Crist for a million dollars
and had him apologize apologize on
YouTube so that he could get remixed and
auto-tuned by everyone I think that's
brilliant that's ridiculous wait tonight
he's gonna yes he did the whole day
actually can you look up and set up the
apology look at a trilogy
phantomon yes part of the settlement is
that garlic root has to apologize on
YouTube so that it can be our IFC and
auto-tune and main initiative from
people on YouTube so the humiliation
continues and that's that's the most
brilliant part of the whole thing yes
and it'll be there forever it's part of
the part of the settlement is like you
can't take this shit down hi i'm charlie
crist
during 2010 and i ran for a seat in the
United States Senate during that
campaign a video advertisement utilized
a song made famous by David Byrne and
the Talking Heads called road to nowhere
the advertisement was posted on my
campaign website on YouTube and sent out
via email regrettably the campaign did
not ask permission to obtain a license
for mr. Byrne to use road to nowhere in
the advertisement in fact mr. Byrne has
never permitted his songs to be you know
he wrote that shit and I respect the
appellee the use of David Byrne song and
his voice in my campaign advertisement
without his permission was wrong and
should not have occurred I do not
support new I nor do I condone any
actions taken by anyone involved in a
Senate campaign that were inconsistent
with David Burns rights or with any
other artist right Jesus for the very
reason it afforded good for you does
anyone auto-tune this or remix it yeah
yeah oh good let's hear those how about
David Byrne man that's fine is awesome
good job dad stepping up for himself
mmm I hear David Burns from Maryland is
he really that's what I hear
he's funny man I love David Byrne he's
missing charlie crist though does he
have anti-gay policies and stuff
he's probably just the only guy so he
got caught did he get caught well here's
the thing exactly yeah there's this
documentary called outraged by Kirby
dick which is fantastic which talks
about the problem of these people being
closeted like politicians because what
they do is that they end up
self-loathing and then they make a
hurtful and harmful you know laws
against gay people and then their hourly
homophobic and in this Charlie Chris guy
he never seemed to have girlfriends and
then he got married like less than they
interviewed Alfie after he broke up with
the girl the girl that he was gonna
marry when he was gonna run
they you know they separated or whatever
they asked her in the documentary like
is he gay like and she was just like I
really can't talk about it I got paid
some money to not say anything yes it's
like the worst it's worse than somebody
being like know Chuck's cock you're
living in it who cares why does anybody
give a shit no nobody's fucking who
cares but here's the thing the one
interesting thing about the gay thing
that when people go you know where we've
come a long way we progressed is like
with actors no there are no leading men
open actors that's true so there is that
like proof kind of like remember that
guy Kevin Spacey's video he's pretty
open but not you've never come out and
now he's never everyone kind of knows
yeah everyone knows anything like they
take pictures like you'll be proper
Ozzie shots of him we're like a dude
right and you're like they're like out
together and it's like all right these
guys are but he never actually goes you
know what I'm gay or whatever right
because it's out and you almost get the
feeling that if he did you know would he
still get the leading man I don't know
if people are actually that I feel like
you say maybe man did it they probably
get more roles out of the gate they
probably know or three they get a
three-picture deal for some shit they
should but I don't know if it's true I
don't know if it actually would happen
hey is a streaming out working today it
you streams having some crazy show going
on it works like on iPhones and iPads
and that once it's done it's gonna be
able to view what a bunch of faggots huh
yeah meaning its recordings everything's
fine the way oh really yeah really
we'll call me a pussy content see how I
feel about that alright that's hurtful
towards women who you pussy pussy pussy
Ulysses bursts cuz really strong really
cuts deeper I love cunt I love it that's
a great what are your face on it yeah oh
I love it I love eating kind Terry pussy
is more offensive to you than cunt
no no I like the sound of cunt better
than I like the sound to come to yeah
yeah I think cuts one of my top three
sounds yeah cunt is great
the British use contour still got oh you
meant the word that's what she meant the
way it sounded tell yes
tell the story that's really funny I was
telling the story when I was in
Australia about your ex-boyfriend was
this was this in a noir no no we were in
England so boyfriend first you have to
establish how much contas used right
right so in England you know they say
cunt every other word I a fucking cunt
cunt cunt this con that cunt your mother
and it's it's just such a common it's
not even doesn't mean pussy a cunt is
like an asshole right you feel hey yes
so I'm in this pub with my ex-boyfriend
and we're we made friends with these
English people and are nice enough to
fucking tolerate us and hang out and
they keep saying can't count cunt
and so my ex is so he's like I'm getting
into it cool well everyone can say this
and so he asks you know what is this how
come everybody in and they explained to
him when you say cunt when it's your
friends and this and that and then and
there's a girl there and she says
something stupid and he goes yeah you
fucking cunt and silence like record
scratch everybody's like yo you can't
they didn't say yo that only works for
guys you can't call a girl so a girl can
say it Ike to a guy into another girl
probably wrecked but a guy cannot call
it's the same offense as it is here then
when you do that to a woman
yeah the same way yeah men generally use
the terms yeah men use it two men a lot
I mean you see it you know it's
Australian don't be a con stop being a
cunt oh he meant well though he was just
trying to write but it's really funny
that it's just in conversation he's like
he's like whatever you don't yeah whoa
fuck is wrong with you man we should
tell how I wrapped these jeans up right
practice jeans and tight what am i what
are you what are you doing next Ryan
what you're gonna be next
I'm actually tomorrow night I'm doing
the super serious show that shows I'm so
excited and I uh I had to retweet that
does that line up looks yeah I'm excited
about what's the lineup tell them who's
on it Thomas Lennon I think is on aisle
er Brendan wall of me and I can't
remember for the life of me the guy from
UCB and I'm embarrassed I can't it's a
stupid line it is a really salt and then
I'm that show is really fun we both done
yeah you folks on it right that you're
gonna have the best time they match box
studios in Culver City eight o'clock if
you are around tomorrow and you can get
to Culver City I highly recommend that
show yeah I'd be surprised actually if
it's not sold out right now yeah Joel
Mandal porn oh great they put on a show
you don't like holy shit I wish every
show is it's exactly what I think they
have free beer yeah five bucks get you
all you can drink yeah so much it's
fucking rad I think or is it 15 yeah I
can't remember now you guys so that's
tomorrow Thursday night what about
anything after that I'm headlining
Irvine in May May 21st but I go out of
town in like a week and a half for my
brother's wedding and then we jump back
in the swing that's rad well Sacramento
I will be at the punchline this weekend
Thursday through Saturday come out and
see me I would love it and save you've
heard this on the podcast the mom cast
yeah rad yeah Tommy T I'm gonna be a
Thursday through Saturday I'll be at the
comedy magic club in Hermosa Beach and
then in two weeks I'm doing the Hard
Rock The Improv at Fort Lauderdale total
momjo
it's a mom show so mom casted listeners
where you know
most likely the cows will be playing
some portal 2 there's a package that I
need to call ups about okay that's a lot
of good stuff going on thanks thanks for
joining us today Ryan thank you red band